i worry about you
out there in the middle of nowhere all
by yourself the cartels are running
everything through there
drugs people guns i don't scare easy
i've seen darkness
this is the best dog in the world and
i've seen what we can do
come from pima county merchants bank let
you know that the ranches be sold at
auction
i just need a little time to sort things
out
you're never gonna make it it's miles to
the nearest road i'll call border patrol
i come here to take the woman and the
boy i was in the marine corps so i
suggest y'all turn around and adios i'm
a soldier too
my orders are to take them back with me
you're not safe here let's go
what the hell were you thinking taking
that kid they were going to kill them
they were waiting for them at the border
you tell me a lot of appreciate what i'm
doing for you you wanna help me you take
me back i'll find my own way home i'm
taking you to your family in chicago
after that i don't care what you do the
man you saw at the border is from the
vasquez cartel
he'll find you and when he does he will
kill you
[Music]
this kid didn't bring him if this on
himself
he just needs someone to give him a
chance
do you think i like it in chicago there
are good times ahead for you miguel
he's your grandson no his mother asked
me to look after him she must have had a
lot of faith in you
[Music]
foreign
looks like you had a little incident
[Music]
you